Speaker 1: So yesterday, we talked about the covid
Health SCAP that Florida has become sort of almost
like as a feature of how Republican Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis has handled the covid
situation there, really flouting, not flaunting,
flouting all conventional wisdom and public health
guidelines almost from the very
beginning of the pandemic. Now,
we also have these other Republicans who
they've been vaccinated and if asked,
they'll say go and get vaccinated. But for the
most part, throughout the pandemic, they've played
the Freedom and Liberty game and mostly sucked up
to President Donald Trump. And one such example is
Republican senator from representing the state of
South Carolina, Lindsey Graham. Lindsey Graham is
now tested positive for covid-19. And the timing
of that positive test suggests that because of a
boat ride, he went on on Senator Joe Mansions
boat. It may even be a sort of mini super spreader
event. So let's first look at what exactly is
going on. Axios reporting Senator Lindsey Graham
tests positive for covid-19. Senator Lindsey
said yesterday he tested positive despite being
vaccinated. Graham emphasized that the mildness
of his symptoms is due to being vaccinated.
If he had been unvaccinated, his symptoms would
be far worse, he said. That's his speculation,
but certainly reasonable thing to think. It
appears Graham may have exposed a number of other
senators to the virus after he attended a weekend
get together hosted by Senator Joe Manchin,
Democrat from West Virginia, on the latter's
houseboat. CNN reports Senator Manchin is fully
vaccinated and following CDC guidelines for
those exposed to a covid positive individual.
Senators Mark Kelly, Jackie Rosann and Jackie
Rosann were also at the bipartisan gathering
and are now following CDC guidelines for persons
exposed. Senators Catherine Cortez Masto, John
Thune and Chris Coons, all of whom are fully
vaccinated, also attended the boat gathering.
Thune has already received his test results and
tested negative for covid. Senate Democrats have
gone back to holding virtual meetings in light of
the news of Graham's positive test. So I haven't
really thought about Lindsey Graham for some time.
But remember that crazy situation where he refused
to be covid tested before a debate with I believe
it was Jamie Harrison who is running against him
for the Senate in 2020. And so they basically
install the plastic shield around Lindsey Graham.
Sometimes you'll see at big concerts, the drummer
will have a plastic shield so that the drumming
doesn't get picked up by the microphones
of other instruments and people on stage.
They did the equivalent, but with Lindsey it was
a covid glass plexi, Plexiglas or plastic barrier
because he didn't want to be tested. So the point
here is Lindsey Graham has been relatively clear
over the last two weeks, including now with his
positive test. I thanks to being vaccinated,
this is probably less serious than it otherwise
would have been. Go and get vaccinated. It's
important to be vaccinated. But for basically
the totality of 20-20, he sucked up to Trump
and insisted Trump was doing a good job on covid,
despite Trump's jab jab on covid being one of the
worst in the world, particularly for what we would
call one of the wealthier countries, refused to be
tested as part of his freedom and all of this
other stuff. And now he may have been involved
in a potential mini spreader event. Now, again,
the the senators on Joe Mansion's vote Saturday
were, of course, Joe Manchin himself, Mark Kelly,
Chris Coons, John Thune. I mentioned Jackie Rosen,
Senator Cantwell from Washington, and Senator
Cortez Masto from Nevada. And hopefully all of
them will will test negative. So there's been a
really interesting you know what, at this point,
it's really depressing, actually, that this is the
way it is. But signal and the absence of signal,
both are being computed the same way by the anti
maskers and the anti voxels. When you so you would
think, oh, OK, Lindsay tested positive despite
being vaccinated and his symptoms are mild. So
that should lead people to say I should get
vaccinated so that if I test positive, my
symptoms will be mild. The problem is that you'll
have some people in his base who will say, oh,
he was vaccinated and tested positive.
Therefore, the vaccine doesn't work.
That would be one incorrect interpretation
of what happened here. And they'll say, so
I won't get vaccinated because it didn't prevent
Lindsay from testing positive. The other one is,
well, he tested positive and it's. Child, so
therefore, I don't have to go and get vaccinated,
ignoring the reality that there's a good chance,
we don't know for sure, but there's a good chance
that Lindsay's case is milder and hopefully it
remains milder because he was vaccinated. So
to you and me, we would say this is the this is
the virtue of the vaccines working. Lindsay is
I don't know, he must be around between 65
and 70, I would guess 67, something like that.
He is at a higher chance of a more serious case.
He says it's like a cold right now. It's mild and
he is vaccinated. So this is the virtue of getting
vaccinated. Other people will simply find in that
what they want. Either you don't need
a vaccine against something that's mild
or you don't need a vaccine that doesn't
work because he tested positive despite being
vaccinated. So unfortunately, it's not going to
be the big boon that you and I might hope. Now,
hopefully he recovers and then he encourages
people to get vaccinated and at least some of
them listen and understand that this change we've
seen from people like, you know, Mitch McConnell
claims he's been for the vaccine all along. He
got vaccinated. He hasn't been loudly for the
vaccine all along. Fox News, you know, everybody
turning pro vaccine. Now, the reason in part,
we know that the Trump administration early
didn't really do that much about covid
is they saw it mostly affecting Democratic blue
cities, New York City, Boston, San Francisco,
Los Angeles, etc.. And so we know because of the
conversations between Jared Kushner and Trump,
they just weren't worrying about it that much
because it was mostly affecting their political
opponents, adversaries, enemies or
whatever, whatever the case may be. Now,
it is a very different situation. Now, the number
one covid Health SCAP in the country is Florida,
with often twenty or thirty percent of the entire
country's cases are happening in Florida each day.
Hospitalizations record in Florida over ten
thousand highest of the entire pandemic covid
case rates growing twice as quickly on average
in red counties that voted Trump versus blue
counties that voted Biden. So they realize
now they are the ones at risk of losing voters
because of that political reality. That's why
they're changing their perspective. Hopefully,
Lindsay testing positive Phil Valentine, the radio
host who was anti vaccine get vaccinated. I'm
now on a ventilator. Hopefully this gets people
vaccinated. But unfortunately, I think for many
of the anti vaccines, they will see this and say,
oh, this is more reason not to get vaccinated.